quel monde après la crise planétaire du
coc vide 19 les initiatives locales et
solidaire vont-elles se généraliser des
actions à l'image des systèmes
d'échangés locaux les celles nées au
canada et expérimenté en france dès les
années 90 hier giro ne va pas promener
les chiens dans les marques prouvost il
s'agit en fait d'un contrat des changes
entre deux associés du sel le système
d'échangé local un mode économie fondée
sur le troc le premier système d'échangé
local français voit le jour en ariège en
1995 le principe échangés au sein d'un
groupe des biens et des services hors du
circuit monétaire classique unité le
grain de sel permet de comptabiliser le
temps de service matérialisé par ses
bons des changes
on ne parle plus des mots d'achat de
vente de monnaie sont privés on les
élimine de nous mêmes
puisqu'on ne parle que des changes et le
sel c'est surtout une grande
convivialité une grande fraternité d'une
grande solidarité dans le réseau l'idée
fait tache d'huile
très vite des selles indépendants se
développe dans toute la france
l'hérault la dordogne et même paris
constitue leur propre réseau à cette
époque l'économie française est encore
fragilisée par la récession de 92 93
ce système solidaire permet donc à
certains chômeurs ou retraités de
retrouver un pouvoir d'achat en berne
mais aussi d'avoir une vie un niveau de
vie un petit peu plus élevé que ce que
j'avais dans la mesure où effectivement
avec les échanges moi je vais pouvoir
acheter des légumes je pouvoir acheter
la violence je suis pouvoir là je viens
de faire remettre l'électricité à angers
l'électricité dans la maison que
j'habite
ça me permet fait qu'ils demandent vivre
peu près normalement mais cette économie
parallèle interpelle le gouvernement
ces services sans valeur monétaire est
donc exonéré d'impôt sont un manque à
gagner pour l'état en 1997 cet
économiste de la répression des fraudes
mettait en garde si les règles ne sont
pas respectées il ya un risque de
travail au noir d'économie souterraine
et c'est ce qu'il faut éviter
faudrait pas que les scènes sont un
moyen d'échapper à la tva quand celle ci
est due les systèmes d'échangés locaux
sont donc toléré à condition qu'il
s'agisse d'une activité non répétitive
mais après chaque crise ces coups de
main loin de l'économie traditionnelle
refont surface
exemple au sel de l'île après la crise
de 2008
je pense qu'avec la crise les gens vont
d'eux de force
apprendre à raisonner autrement et
effectivement petit à petit quitter la
société société du gaspillage et de la
surconsommation un discours qui résonne
encore aujourd'hui en france plus de 600
systèmes d'échangés locaux sont répartis
sur tout le territoire et depuis le
début de la crise du coc vide 19
d'autres structures ont vu le jour
[Musique]